حسنًا، للأسف، إليك ما نعرفه بعد
قراءة هذا التقرير المكون من 30 صفحة من
مكتب الفاحص الطبي، فقد أدرجوا
التأثيرات الحادة للكيتامين كسبب
لوفاته، ووفاة ماثيو بيري بالإضافة
إلى مرض الشريان التاجي الغارق
وتأثيرات البوبرينورفين الآن،
لإعطائك بعض السياق  من الكيتامين أه، وجدوا
الجرعات التي وجدوها أن المستويات التي
وجدوها كانت حوالي 3200 نانوجرام لكل
ملليلتر ولإخبارك بما يعنيه ذلك،
يمكن أحيانًا استخدام الكيتامين في
التخدير وعادةً ما
تُرى المستويات هناك بين 1000 و6000،
لذلك كان لديه الكثير  هناك نقطتان مهمتان من الكيتامين في
نظامه، لا يزال من
النادر جدًا حتى عند تلك
المستويات أن يموت شخص ما بسبب
تسمم الكيتامين، ولسوء الحظ كان
أيضًا في حمام السباحة في ذلك الوقت
ويبدو أن ذلك
مع الكيتامين هو على الأرجح ما  أدى إلى
وفاته كما أخبرنا أحد الفاحصين الطبيين
أه ربما لم يكن الكيتامين هو ما
انتهى به الأمر إلى قتله ولكنه جعل من
الممكن له أن يغرق أم هذا
نوع ما نعرفه في هذه المرحلة أنهم
يعرفون أنه تم العثور على بعض الكيتامين في
معدته مما يوحي بأنه
ابتلعها يمكن أن يؤخذ الكيتامين وهو
يبتلعه يمكنك شمه يمكنك حقنه وهناك
نوع مختلف من معدلات الحقن في البداية من
الواضح أنه الأسرع إذا ابتلعته
فقد يستغرق الأمر نصف ساعة  ساعة
حتى يصبح ساري المفعول، لذلك من الممكن
أنه تناول هذا الكيتامين قبل أن يصبح له
أي تأثير بالفعل، لقد كان في
حمام السباحة أه، تسبب الكيتامين في
تفكك كبير وهو ما
يفعله عادةً وهذا
ما أدى في النهاية إلى غرقه أيضًا  كان لديه
البوبرينورفين في نظامه وهو مادة
أفيونية اصطناعية لا نعرف لماذا
كان يجمعها معًا ولكن في بعض الأحيان
يمكن استخدام البوبرينورفين بالفعل
للمساعدة في تخفيف بعض
التأثيرات المهلوسة لشيء مثل الكيتامين، إنها
قصة حزينة، إنها مجرد حزينة  في كل
مكان ولكن هذا ما
خلص إليه الطبيب الشرعي أن الكيتامين
بالتزامن مع وجوده في
حمام السباحة هو على الأرجح ما أدى إلى وفاته